[Musik]
mein name ist uwes leute und leute ich
bin kommandant des portfolios 14
das fahrzeug 14 ist dass panzer problem
des heeres und der kern mechanisierten
landesverteidigung
wir verfügen über 48 charakter und diese
sind insgesamt drei kompanien gegliedert
[Musik]
die aufgabe der panzer warte ist es im
zuge der militärischen
landesverteidigung sowohl in der
verteidigung als auch im angriff die
wertvolle unterstützung für die
grenadiere verbände sicherzustellen und
selbstständig im panzer gelände
anzugreifen und feind zu werfen
beim handwerk geht es in bar 2014 vor
allem warum seinem und soldaten
gemeinsam mit dem cover soldaten
verstärkt durch die grundwehrdiener
militärischen landesverteidigung zur
schule
dafür haben wir eine kampfansage company
gegliedert die angriffs weise vorgeht
und damit die weitere bewegung der
brigade sicherstellen
[Musik]